de camino a casa judith desde su escuela
corrió durante la mitad de la distancia
luego brinco durante un cuarto del resto
del recorrido y camino el resto de
camino a casa ella caminó por un total
de 360 pies cuál es la distancia entre
la escuela y la casa de judith y dice
que escribas la respuesta en yardas así
que hay un pequeño truco aquí pues dice
que son 360 pies y que escribas tu
respuesta en yardas
entonces recordemos que una yarda es
igual a tres pies por lo que tenemos que
tener cuidado de no cometer errores
entonces de ahora en adelante la
información la vamos a ir dando en
yardas
entonces 360 pies cuantas la razón y
bien son tres pies por yarda por lo que
entonces dividimos estos 360 pies entre
tres y a dividir lo tendríamos 120
yardas así que ya tenemos dicho problema
en términos de yardas
ahora pensemos en esto si tenemos la
distancia entera digamos que esta es la
distancia entera por lo que aquí esta
sería la escuela y luego dibujando toda
esta línea que nos mostrará la distancia
de todo el camino a casa de judith y
bueno lo haré lo más larga posible para
verlo bien y escribir sobre ella
entonces esta es la escuela y acá está
la casa y bien primero nos dice el
problema que ella corrió la mitad de la
distancia así que digamos que sería por
aquí y ella corrió la mitad de la
distancia que sería esto que estoy
coloreando y luego dice que ella brincó
durante un cuarto del resto de la
distancia y seamos claros la distancia
restante es la que tenemos todavía así
que marquemos el cuarto de la distancia
restante y por aquí hasta la mitad luego
tenemos un cuarto luego dos cuartos y
tres cuartos lo que hicimos fue dividir
en cuatro la distancia restante
que ella brincó un cuarto de dicha
distancia entonces este de color morado
sería el cuarto de la distancia que
brincó luego nos dice que ella camino el
resto del camino a casa y ella camino el
resto de camino a casa por lo que esto
sería lo que ella camino lo cual esta
distancia de por aquí son las 120 yardas
cuál es la distancia entre la escuela y
la casa de judía y sólo una serie de
maneras en cómo puedes pensar esto
cuando nosotros hablamos de la distancia
que resta después de correr donde esta
es la distancia restante después de que
ella corrió que es la parte naranja
donde esta sección de color azul son los
tres cuartos de la distancia restante y
representan a 120 yardas de la distancia
restante entonces estos son tres cuartos
de la distancia de la distancia restante
así que cuánto es un cuarto de dicha
distancia restante entonces si estos son
los tres cuartos un cuarto sería un
cuarto de esto un cuarto de 120 yardas
es 40 por lo que cada uno de estos de
aquí son 40 entonces al sumar 43 veces
nos dan a 120 yardas y luego esta de
aquí también está de aquí serían 40
yardas todo en términos de yardas por lo
que dicha distancia restante 40 por 4
nos darán los 160 yardas entonces son
160 yardas y entonces cuál es la
distancia total bien estas 160 yardas es
la distancia restante después de que
ella corriera lo cual es la mitad de la
distancia total entonces y éstas también
son 160 yardas
así que 160 yardas más 160 nos dan las
320 yardas